Community has got to be about its
members seeing each other
not just seeing a principal not just
serving a principal and so it's used a
lot flippantly in Internet language
especially oh my community my community
my it's your audience
it's your customer a customer base is
not a community
an audience is not a community an
audience online
is not a community until the people can
really see each other I don't think it's
the most robust form of community and so
we can get into shades of grading around
like how intense is your community how
well thought out or how deep is it but I
think the high water mark for all of us
using that word is
can people connect to each other is
there a level of self-organization
self-actualization possible through the
members of that Community having agency
of Their Own